[Music]
Dance Moms just hasn't been the same
since you and your sister Mackenzie left
the show but we're gonna after the
season not be on the elite team anymore
[Music]
we miss you Maddie but luckily for us
you're still making headlines you're on
your way to becoming one of the best
known dancers in the world your schedule
is fully loaded and you're traveling the
world and wrapping new brands so we have
to ask Maddie how do you factor in your
downtime and how do you juggle your fame
and your boyfriend at the same time
Maddie Ziegler has been super busy since
she left Dance Moms and so has the rest
of the cast from touring to filming
dance videos to graduating from school
there's nothing the og cast of Dance
Moms can't do keep watching to find out
there are real ages and relationships
Mackenzie Ziegler Kenzie is by far one
of the most popular dancers in America
she's young talented and has her entire
career ahead of her with over 13 million
followers on her Instagram page it's
hard to believe that Kinsey is only 15
years old she was born on June 4th 2004
and quickly rose to fame on the hit
reality TV show Dance Moms back in 2016
candy was rumoured to be dating the
famous youtuber Johnny Orlando however
Kinsey did date ashtin our BAP but sadly
the couple broke things off as of right
now Kinsey appears to be single Jojo
Siva Jojo is known for her loud
personality and unique sense of style
she's outspoken and devoted to her fans
which is why she's become such a famous
personality but we make dreams come true
oh yeah and she can dance like there's
no tomorrow
Jojo with the Bobo was born on may 19
2003 making her 16 years old today she's
currently single but she did date singer
Maddie be back in 2015 there were rumors
that Jojo was secretly dating someone
but she cleared them up by telling her
fans that she wouldn't be able to keep a
boyfriend a secret Abby Lee Miller
there's no one in the world quite like
Abby Lee Miller she's driven opinionated
and 100% dedicated to the ALDC
Abby spends nearly every single waking
moment teaching her students how to
dance
you have the mascot it's evil yes she's
52 years old but has never been in a
serious relationship she was born on
September 21st 1966 but has never tied
the knot or had children back in 2017
Abbi convinced the world that she was
dating Geordi Rodriguez however Geordi
later revealed that their relationship
was scripted for the camera Kendall
vertes Kendall was born on December 9th
2002 she's 16 years old and already one
of the biggest stars of her generation
kendall has over 1 million followers on
her YouTube channel Kendall K this Dance
Moms original member used to date Austin
Winkler but she recently started dating
John rink in 2019 Paige Hyland Paige
Hyland is 18 years old and living her
best life she was born on November 1st
2000 and is known for being one of Abby
Lee Miller's least favorite dancers she
told me I'm terrified for Abby to watch
me dance
after leaving Dance Moms due to its
toxic environment Paige decided to focus
on her studies and came up winning she
used to date her on-and-off-again
boyfriend Nick Kelly but the couple
split in 2018 Paige is currently dating
Jay vine thrift and they're super cute
together
Chloe the cave Zack Chloe has managed to
maintain her popularity since leaving
Dance Moms
she has over 2 million followers on
YouTube and 6 million on Instagram and
she's only 18 years old Chloe was born
on May 25th 2001 making her a Gemini she
dated Puerto Rican actor
Ricky Garcia from 2015 to 2016 however
Chloe has chosen to remain single since
the split she's focusing on herself and
reaping the benefits
Nia sue Nia was born on June 20th 2001
flaw she may only be 18 years old Nia
has accomplished so much throughout her
young life that's one of my strongest
of dance and I'm just really excited Nia
isn't currently seeing anyone she's
single and loving it but she used to
date Brice Xavier back in 2018 before
the couple called it quits it was an
amicable breakup which led Bryce to
write sing and post the song and goodbye
to ex-girlfriend to social media
Kalani Hilliker Kalani was born on
September 23rd mm she's 18 years old and
living the life she always dreamed of
she's an actress and a dancer who loves
traveling and attending big music
festivals Kalani is currently single but
she's dated two people in the past
Kalani has been in relationships with
Hayes Dreyer and Brandon Chang back in
2014 if Kalani is currently dating
someone she's keeping it a secret
bream rum follow Bren was born on July
1st 2003 I can be Abby's number-one
soloist while she may only be 16 years
old she's a highly accomplished teenager
with a huge following Fran is currently
dating Hunter birth and the happy couple
loves to post adorable pictures of
themselves on insta Hunter's on the
football team and Brynn is a cheerleader
they're basically made for each other
Brooke Highlands Brooke was born on
January 30th 1998 because Abby already
hates us and she's probably gonna hate
me more after doing this dance she's got
over 3 million Instagram followers and
is truly living her best life brooke
dated her highschool boyfriend
Nolan Betts for a super long time
unfortunately their relationship came to
an end in 2017 Maddie Ziegler it's easy
to forget that Maddie is only 16 years
old she was born on September 30th 2002
and quickly rose to fame she's one of
the most successful American dancers of
all time back in 2016 Maddie dated
Instagram star Jack Kelly however the
couple split up sometime in 2018
Maddie has been dating Kyle and Morris
since October 2018 and fans can't get
over how good they look together which
one of these couples do you ship the
most tell us in the comments thanks for
watching hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time on the things
[Music]